as they predict evict Atlas arrow Misha
covet kazoo not be landing Ponton
criterion catcus when you except an
official ethnic okay captain Evita
bodies Festa case okay webcast not be
than the pontoon cross paddock fest
solely Tamaki fischeri Terry Malloy
battle royale Casa Bella bond film you
get well yeah better puts a doula bono
catch the eye but your key card cash
fell so Rachel and concession that cabin
but hast nya kaha do manual and cos aged
volume intranet we're entering coming
actually develop a fish a look
electronic whoosh Alicia and cast ethnic
would meet AutoCAD Pentacles mallesh
theorem by our eternal tollana Coco
vodkas V tank born makin sudhi kabhi
soch Agni rod causative all LM BT
Sameach else Anthony near vanish macumba
status is delayed by said bel-air tousle
MBT mantis Eva's etiquette east attempt
on Evita banished kerim would catch the
I work a cottage vessel as a shot a band
marrows hermandad Prasad rocket or
common sack and a source distillate
resurrected tell my bag Patricia Kaas
anthem Cecily emerged from it Ibiza
Chang Navy banished la cerva tiny tone
of Nakia Omega sought welcome thank you
very much mana president good evening
honorable members of the Parliament
thank you for this opportunity to speak
to you about the development in Poland
as regard the LDT LGBTI community I
would like to express my strong concerns
on this as you know the European
Commission has been closely monitoring
the development and the accounts of
recent events that have reached the
Commission are very worrying in
particularly last July an equality March
organised in the publicity of Biello
stock that was intended to be peaceful
was met with an avalanche of verbal and
physical violence and hate speech
directed at the participants LD t be
free sown stickers were distributed by a
Polish newspaper moreover several Polish
regional and local authorities have
adopted declaration statements or
resolutions branding LGBTI community
postulates as an ideology and declaring
their territories LD to be unwelcome
all this is securing in a climate of
rising anti-lgbt i that
rhetoric in the run-up to the polish
parliamentary election that took place
last month the European Commission
strongly condemns these development any
former discrimination intolerance or
violence based on sexual orientation
gender identity or sex characteristics
goes against the fundamental values of
the European Union that are founded in
article 2 in the treaty and in addition
article 21 of the shorter fundamental
rights of the European Union which has
the same legal values as the treaties
prayer bits any discrimination on the
grounds of sexual orientation and sex
some of the Polish authorities that have
adopted anti LGPL DBT I resolutions
declarations of statements are managing
authorities or beneficiaries of
operational programs supported by the EU
structural and investment funds and on
October 23rd this year the Commission
met with Polish authorities in the
framework of an annual review meeting of
the regional operational program at a
financed or co-financed by the European
Regional Development Fund and the
European Social Fund and we stressed the
need to respect EU law including the
Charter in the implementation of these
program particularly the principle of
non-discrimination by issuing anti LGBTI
resolutions declarations or statement
polish managing authorities and
beneficiaries of the EU structural and
investment funds raised doubts if
they're of their ability to ensure
respect of the Charter and the
Commission will continue to monitor the
situation in Poland and we will engage
with Poland to make sure incidents of
this kind never happen again
discrimination violates and hate speech
against the LGBTI community must be
stopped in the European Union thank you
very much for this possibility to have
the debate I'm looking forward to your
questions thank you thank you very much
for your opening remarks Marcus a new
caucus the gondola toccatas magdalena
Dom Ovid sarcastic Evita capers
Benedetti Pinner